among the
modeling and research that you dug into
was peter turchins model among them
where he has this political stress index
uh he's out of the university of
connecticut i believe and
uh it shows for him in their model which
includes a lot of different factors
including lack of opportunity for
educated elites
uh nutrition like a bunch of different
factors go into it but his
study showed political stress to be at
literally civil war levels which is one
of the reasons why i take this
uh possibility very seriously
yeah well yeah i mean the fact that
there's like barbara walters books that
uses a completely separate methodology
from mine but comes to the exact same
conclusions i mean that's a bit of a
warning right like you could i i didn't
go through that model although i was
familiar with it i went through prio the
peace
research institute of oslo because i i
felt they had a sort of um
like a slightly more uh well i wouldn't
it would be fair to say more global but
like they they were they were not in
america right and part of the thing that
i wanted was to get like perspectives
outside of america on america because i
find like the debate in america is so
toxic that it kind of consumes like
everyone gets consumed within it um and
so yeah i mean he he that that's a
that's excellent research though um but
you know the the
the models that i used um are more
specifically tied to inequality like the
and though and those uh vertical
inequality and horizontal inequality
both which are you know literally at
levels that the republic has never seen
before like there's never been high
higher inequality back in back in 1776
there was not this level of inequality
yeah we're in the new strange gilded age
uh uh supercharged by
uh technology
uh and capitalism in different ways so
when you talk about a horizontal
inequality versus vertical inequality
explain i have a sense that vertical
inequality is the inequality that most
people think of
well inequality is like they're high
level there are some people who are very
rich and there are some people are very
poor um america of course is the real
extreme example of this globally where
uh you have you have like i mean it's
just it's off the charts like it's the
genie coefficient is just so so crazy in
the united states that it basically
breaks all the models a horizontal
inequality is inequality between groups
so inequality between ethnic groups
between different identified between
different regions uh between different
identifiable groups and both are very
high in the in the united states um and
both you know are predictors of civil
war i mean you know like some people ask
me what are the most common things that
lead into it um
you know the the
anarchy is probably the biggest one but
i don't really like to think of it that
way because to me
it's a complex cascading system it's
something where everything feeds into
itself and that's why you get
such turbulence right like that's why
the unimaginable keeps happening all the
time like why it's like you just can't
believe something happened because
it it i think a lot of americans have
had that sense it's like oh that that
like i can't believe that's happening
but now it's almost commonplace
um so you just used a term enocracy uh
can you explain like societies that are
ripe for
civil war and for political violence
generally are not democracies or
um autocracies those are both very
stable like there's there's not gonna be
a revolution in russia it's an autocracy
there's not going to be a revolution in
canada god willing although god knows
we've come
close twice to losing the country in my
lifetime but uh and there was martial
law declared just before i was born but
um you know those those kind of
societies tend not to have lots of
political violence it's where you're in
this in between space the gray area like
the fake democracy the democracy that no
one has actual faith in exactly and
that i mean america is that now i think
and i agree it is yeah we will very much
resemble a democracy for reasons that
you know like i'm i i'm very animated
about i i and i think like one of the
things about you is that the rights
always kind of made that argument like
the right has always sort of said like
they're not legitimate but now it's
people on the left and people with data
and people with not emotions but out of
reason saying uh you know this is not a
functioning
system anymore
some of the reasons why i think america
has become a fake democracy is that you
have this two-party system that is very
rigidly enforced
and now 83 to 90 of congressional races
are gerrymandered to be safely blue or
safely red so that there's no real
uncertainty around which party is going
to emerge from that seat victorious to
the extent that any uncertainty exists
is in the primary
which ends up distorting incentives in
various ways but it does mean that if
you're in the minority party in 90 of
the country you might as well just not
vote or sit it out um and so when people
go and exhort you to be like oh get
involved do this it's like we've
actually set it up so that you can have
no
meaningful impact
on
this race but we're going to inflame you
we're going to make you mad in in
various ways um so that this
system i i think is very very
discouraging to
uh many many americans uh it's not a
genuine democracy in that if you did
have uh like an independent actor or
party or candidate the odds of them
actually being able to make headway are
vanishingly
low because you would need 10 million
dollars to run a statewide campaign like
what independent could have that uh you
know if you're an ordinary citizen
you're
on the outside looking in so you get
told look you have to play within these
parties which by the way
again um you know like uh aren't really
open unto themselves you have this
strange media landscape that's hyper
polarized and uh gutted at the local
level so here's those so those are some
of the things i i think about when i
think fake democracy which is a
different argument than the stuff that
you've heard from let's say
uh the right in times past
no that's true i mean
to me as an outsider like the the
the inherent fairness of any electoral
system is kind of not really relevant
because what matters is that people feel
the system to be legitimate i mean
that's the basis of peaceful government
like like we have a first-past-the-post
system here which you know has it
definite you could like some sometimes
the majority party wins with 39 of the
vote right and everyone's you know sort
of outraged but then you know this is
just the system your system is designed
that way i mean how many political yeah
exactly active in canada
uh three well more there's at least four
actually but um
and you know sometimes one is like one
it's currently a minority government
with the third party being the king
maker really right now the ndp but my
point really is that
that's all fine and good until ordinary
people like you can survive all of that
until ordinary people start to feel that
their system is not representing the
popular will and i mean the evidence is
really becoming clear that that that is
that is happening that ordinary
americans don't feel that their
electoral system represents the popular
will and as you like for all the reasons
you just said that's a perfectly
rational uh point of view to hold right
and you know and the other thing is it's
only it's about to get much worse you
know like it's about to get much
dramatically worse
[Music]
you